how's Cumbres my name me llamo is booty
back come over to topi na selva bina it
did well okay welcome to layers of fear
should have a little bit more energy
today Jesus Christ I was tired oh look
at the most beautiful dream last night I
dreamt he came to me embraced me loved
me as he once did but we both know that
while I dreamed my silly little dream it
was you it was you
he really lusted for so who is you could
it be a painting maybe because he seemed
to be obsessed with his art he forgot
about his wife you know he forgot about
his kid why wouldn't he okay we're at
the baby chapter and I don't think I
realized this but the holy [ __ ] did
that's a dog
this house have a lot of rooms in it
doesn't it alright where's the baby man
oh man oh man where the [ __ ] are you
baby am I supposed to click this oh yeah
I remember this is an object it's locked
though so we need to find a key all
right please please baby can I have a
key baby no oh I had one of those those
are fun oh here we go
better better better then that didn't
sound right awesome now I can't move in
did that unlock it perhaps it did not
well then isn't this the favorite
episode you've ever had watch Peter pie
gets stuck while playing video games
quality entertainment oh boy I would pay
to watch this put this on YouTube bread
please
oh well then that looks like a item we
could use no how about in this got it
there noon have to wind it up first
person action on this [ __ ] hey kitty how
you doing hey dougie what's up you're
the man dog who's the man now dog sorry
had to oh so cute
unless cute
oh oh that's funny I'm sorry
and now they're gonna because
well that went better than expected
glad we did that well never mind then
yeah I remember playing this this is the
last thing we played since was a special
brush Oh like a horsehair brush but
different can't see much from that any
wind I hesitated will this really work
[ __ ] it [ __ ] I was already halfway
through and besides it's not like I can
just put it all back and forget the
whole thing that's when you say [ __ ] it
wrong door I'm so sorry
let me close that okay so I think this
is where this is where we left off
so after this this is gonna turn into
kind of like a face like thing if I
remember yeah that's it that's it oh
it's so creepy and that was number four
we need two more and two more is the
last of the game and hopefully I'll get
scared oh my god not one of these
[ __ ] corridors again what kind of
[ __ ] drugs are my on ji OH
oh god not the monster the monster
scares me
oh god it's sign okay here we go that's
locked this is a chest it's locked as
well everywhere is ain't everything lost
these [ __ ] days well [ __ ] me I don't
know where that key is hey don't do that
who's doing this oh where they like Oh
Oh God there it is Oh God Oh Jeff no huh
oh it's so much scarier when you don't
know what's gonna happen oh my god
okay look like this is the place to be
all right all right
whoo [ __ ] with my books man maybe
there's a book we need to pull like a
classic old puzzle am i right ladies I
am right I thought that was a book on
the ground or some [ __ ]
it's weird cuz a lot of times when you
get stuck you're actually supposed to go
back in this game so I was like oh
that's hot that's some kinky [ __ ] man
they they did better things back in the
day I don't know what staying that here
we go oh [ __ ] that
no thank you I'm gonna go in here [ __ ]
you now if that breaks I swear to God
hello
I don't know what just happened to my
body but I feel like I I did not give
consent to that [ __ ] oh we're back what
the what the what what was that no
perhaps in here breasts some wine well
thank you appreciate it
can we turn on this light Hey much
better now it's nice and cozy isn't it
are we supposed to be here perhaps no
this is a lot never mind then jesus
[ __ ] christ what do you want from me
a mouse traps a documents hey hey we
can't go in there and hear it's too
[ __ ] dark to see where to go so
that's
here's something it could be the wind
but I'm not entirely sure
well then game you win this round but
I've seen here no that's okay something
here how did I miss that
that must have arrived later I sure Jeff
died big time
yeah blah [ __ ] my's scared me and I'm
gonna get scared by mouse I'm not a lot
[ __ ] okay
can we walk here oh [ __ ] oh is that all
right nice EMU mama come I get you come
I come I come I come I come I come me
well then this was entertaining I
suppose we will walk backwards now well
I I enjoyed it no we're not supposed to
goddamn I'm sorry I [ __ ] suck
sometimes it's not about video games
it's about having fun and oh boy are we
not having fun right now so I don't know
why I just said there it is
no nevermind there's a brick wall some
[ __ ] I don't know what to tell you oh my
god
[ __ ] you game alright I'm gonna [ __ ] you
okay ouch tiny you are come here come
here you piece of [ __ ] goddamn what is
all this
you ruined my life you piece of crap
you're trash hey hey hey
laughs uncle you son of a [ __ ] I gave
you seven years over my life what is it
alright so so the cat dog rat this is
the puzzle well all you got to do is
call my name and I'll be there it's this
is really a puzzle so we followed the
right right six eight seven could that
be it I'm sure there's a locker here
we're the number on it soon notice no
that was not it oops
no I'm not ah no
okay well let's rethink it six eight
okay well maybe I'm wrong then the dog
has a picture of it so I'm just gonna
assume that's what we need then - five
wait they have different colors as well
does that matter
- five nine let's try that see what
happens
to 500k I don't know what to tell you
that it really make any sense did it
like why would I tie my dog after
following a rat for five seconds that's
the key here now no all right awesome
I'm glad I mean lock that light lock
really helpful [ __ ] man oh my god this
[ __ ] again [ __ ] you pity pity pass
biggest enemy well I'm not going there
oh whoa what baby babe you know once I
get the hold of this baby I'm gonna snap
its [ __ ] neck I'm so tired of demon
babies it's the only right thing to do
whether you like it or not thank you now
that game opens doors for me that 71
whoa
what is going on Hegel uh me globe all
right
I don't have much to say yeah there's
just [ __ ] shitty flooring that's all
that makes sense what are you looking at
oh what a selfish bastard oh there's an
eye that's kind of creepy hello hello
hello-oh looking at me okay that's
we'll take it all in boggle boys I know
I look good
I gotta say the jump-scares
they've been going on for over an hour
now and you kind of get two cents and a
scent of thighs to whatever the right
word is to them I love it I kind of miss
the interaction with the the monster
they really set the tone for the game
sorry I haven't written you in a while
I've been swamped with work I gotta tell
you your last letter was troubling to
say the least
I just can't believe she would set fire
to your old paintings
what a [ __ ] the lady in black
especially that was your tribute to I
wasn't it I don't know what to tell you
except to get some professional help
pronto
you could probably talk to someone as
well with all that's happened I'm sure
it will do to you some good I probably
don't need to tell you that the buyer
was sorely disappointed with the news
the new pieces just aren't telling as
well as to Coolatta classics anyway I'll
be looking you just hang in there and
focus on your work I know you still have
it in you I believe it you your friend
and agent Thomas can't win I don't want
French thing in the end hey that's a
beautiful vase all my paintings are
missing my wife burned them what a
burning yes Hey yeah never stay on track
the game I feel like we're missing a
piece of the puzzle and I'm saying god
damn it's hard to see like I if you
don't think you can see anything don't
worry because I can't see [ __ ] either
all right oh yeah bladder day so darn if
it does ballet that was good
Hey oh it's a [ __ ] chair again see I
want to chase him give me give me a
chase scene
let me run for my life like a little pig
well I'm not gonna go where all their
demons smooshes that's what my mom told
me here to pack yeah
don't look back well I'm gonna trust it
the text right well what the [ __ ] is
this a little pain goes a long way I'm
still not gonna look back oh [ __ ] that's
awesome
all right what do we got
ah
shut up aw don't be such a little [ __ ]
it's fine I'm just pulling the chain but
it's connected to someone's dick I'm
sorry that was unnecessarily vulgar
there we go hey we did it without the
crying [ __ ] up her ass look at that
beautiful water hey it's my best friend
Massie moon we're gonna make it all nice
and cozy in here make it all nice and
cozy gonna make it all nice and cozy
here gonna make it all nice and cozy oh
my greatest enemy the wooden plank well
I shall go this way don't worry about it
there it is
god dammit my house is so dirty Edgar he
[ __ ] smashed the place
what a dick you don't realize oh you put
painting up and down now god I hate him
thought we were god damn it what are you
what he set up a puzzle for me now Edgar
what's the puzzle this time I don't have
there's a cabinet there I probably need
a key for it though
sorry what are you trying to tell me
upside down man listen I can't tell you
when you're whispering Oh God
can I move no oh oh that was creepy
that was very creepy oh god I still can
what do i do then this is so annoying in
games what are you oh here we go it's
hopeless
I I just can't take it anymore anymore
might as well try to paint with both of
my arms broken what what the [ __ ] I
might as well paint with both of my arms
broken
what is this [ __ ] a guy from Dark
Souls Irish Donis Harry Harry
whatever yep wide glide I did that
thanks thanks thanks me I really thought
the game was too bright so it makes
sense for me to do that didn't I get the
key item no guess I did not honestly I
can't see anything
honey I guess it's some kind of joke
like what am I supposed to do I could
have figured out in the light okay
thanks I guess
can I go home now yeah dicks
alright I'm gonna go I'm gonna go down
I'm gonna take a while and sit on this
beautiful little thing and we're gonna
go down thank you
I always forget to close the gate
I'm sure this elevator is safe don't
worry about him sure it's been tested by
scientists eight out of four dentists
recommend this this elevator
hello great glad we're here
hey this is this is good I'm gonna
ignore all that no okay I'm I'm not
gonna ignore it I'm reminded so much by
amnesia
hickory dickory dock the mouse ran up
the clock the clock struck one down
you're right that was hilarious what is
the next item more could it be god I
hate the woman what is that what is this
what am I looking at okay gonna go with
a creepy ladies I guess hello oh my god
wrong room I'm so sorry I didn't know
you were changing she is gonna be pissed
oh look it's mr. baby mr. baby master
baby I am stuck in this hotel how do I
get out oh master baby I pray to your
beard every day please that's it
thank you master baby ah bless me once
again master baby I love you are we
gonna call someone master baby but who
should we call master B master baby
please don't give me those eyes you know
how much I love when you look at me like
that master baby does he have a katana
or samurai sword it from his back or
perhaps if we I have this theory yeah
it's crazy but it might work
yes master baby will give us the answer
master baby mister baby ah that's fine
no big deal whatever Oh master baby baby
face the monster painting oh he didn't
like it something things defy simple
words let alone critique a basic
knowledge of the subject is an absolute
must if one is to even try taming then
baby face is one such painting this art
anomaly draws tens of thousands of
mediocrity enthusiasts and son day
abstraction a fiction and Natalie in
reality it looks like a result of a
week-long art marathon of a not very
well-adjusted painter locked in a dark
basement living aside the horrible
exhibition the painting excels in this
is someone left him a bad review for his
don't listen to a baby face thank you
baby face 360 ah I love you mm baby face
you're my bro
later after this we've got to go to the
hit the gym and we're gonna I'm gonna
spot you so [ __ ] hard
as much is so [ __ ] hard right there
it is another baby face here it is
fuller to watch baby face you know what
I told you about the ceiling night
goddamnit baby face well I don't know
how to get there baby face I'm just
gonna go now oh you're being super lame
right now baby face which one is oh okay
well you know what I'm not gonna spot
you bro yeah baby face more like baby
dick that's a pretty appropriate I mean
baby stupid that's it that's that's the
joke we're gonna go with hello wrong
room
oh [ __ ] alright well this way then I
suppose Oh
I'm not sure if I was supposed to do
that but I think maybe I was I've broken
every bone in my body but I feel great
with enough drugs you can do anything
you want remember remember that kids
don't listen to all this sustain school
messages and don't do drugs I'm telling
you right now as it is do a lot of drugs
and don't stay in school and don't fight
the power scientists got it all wrong
isn't that right baby face that one has
been sitting for a while that little
sneaky [ __ ] I thought for so long I
thought we were through this baby face
maybe I did it wrong I suppose I suppose
we need to redo this part cuz I jumped
down and killed myself that's generally
no oh it's different now well if you had
bad sense of direction before you played
this game you're sure it's how we'll
have worse oh my god do I have to do
that again well as a great man once said
oh that [ __ ] hurt
all right come down lads I know what I'm
doing there it is
hello this pizza delivery I promise
I know I promised to deliver the pizza
within 40 minutes but it's a tough
[ __ ] job oh my god actually that
reminds me last yesterday a pizza
delivery guy got hit by a car and we saw
that the dead body right outside it was
[ __ ] weird it's creepy as hell I
never seen anyone dead before okay
this got more of a I'm gonna man every
time I sneeze I need to do this but I'm
recording a video so I'm just gonna do
that much better
hey mr. baby man oh he switched he
switched to face now this guy Nuart
alright
this guy understood oh my god usually I
just do like that I'm in endorsed and
that's gross you want to hear more about
my snot
yeah feel free to I'll make a Q&A don't
worry about it I baby face it's been a
while man I don't know what to tell you
I'm getting sick of these games I'm
getting sick on this games baby face
okay we're back here awesome it's very
quiet guess the storm went out I guess
we weren't supposed to jump down and
worry
this is awkward cuz I don't have the
phone number like what do you want from
me is that correct I think yes I love
those old phones they're so satisfying
what if we jump on never mind
puzzles are tricky man especially if
you're new idiot like a sim what it's
not like I can hear your help all you
have to do is sit there and being pissed
off how much of an idiot I am
but I appreciate him just know that I
appreciate it that's all you got a no
baby alright up we go I don't know how
I'm walking on all these [ __ ] books
but I can alright baby face we're gonna
have a [ __ ] talk I've died three
times already
now tell me what the number is oh you
pissed me off that beautiful face
I'm gonna find it babyface and when I do
I'm gonna run away without you oh you
test my patience Oh Baby this baby face
more like lay me face yes that's it
that's the joke hmm so we need a number
because I promised something and last
time the baby gave us a number this time
maybe it's more subtle than that I don't
really know a number you know I'm saying
I don't I feel like I expected
everything I'm surely missing something
what happens we walk back here okay
great we can't hmm
tricky tricky tricky tricky tricky it
doesn't tell me a number anywhere
surprises me a PTL at this game as well
all right huh [ __ ] hurts better
dreamish
four-twenty that didn't work
get out of here get out of here maybe if
a360 enough times i will go to heaven
how that looks cool that looks really
cool good job on that one